My name is Nick
Tierney, and I'm here
to talk about the
future of missing data.
So I fully hate missing data.
It disrupts your data
analysis because you
need to stop and work out
how much is missing and think
why is it missing?
Why?
Missing data
controls messages.
I mean, imagine if what I said
just then was bleeped out.
You might get a different
idea of what I was saying.
I redacted hate missing data.
It redacted new data
analysis because redacted
and work out how redacted
is missing and think
why redacted and redacted.
Redacted why?
But the truth is, I
actually love missing data.
In a funny way, understanding.
It's hard, but it has an
extra challenge, a little bit
of spice to a data analysis.
And it's been
something that I found
really exciting and curious
about a data analysis project.
I've actually written
two R packages
to help explore your data
and explore missing data.
And today I'm going to
talk about two things:
a principle of going from
overview to relationship
to explore your missing data
and a brief tour of missing data
visualizations.
Emphasis on the brief.
I won't have time to
explore them all in detail.
So the first one I'd
recommend is an overview.
viz_miss.
This gives you a bird's eye
view of your missing data here.
The rows, your observations and
the columns are your variables.
If we look at the data here, we
see that the black spots here
are missing.
And the gray are present.
And what we take
away from this is
that air temperature
C is missing
and humidity is also missing.
They have two big
chunks of missing data.
There's also a few times where
there's these black streaks
and that indicates that some
variables go missing together.
We also know that there is
extra information on the amount
of missing image variables.
There's 11% missing in
air temperature and 12%
missing in humidity.
So now we go from
the overview here
and we take these
two variables that
are interesting to us,
that have a lot of missing,
and we plot them together
to explore a relationship.
We can do this with ggplot
with air temperature
on the x-axis and
humidity on the y-axis.
But we get a little
interesting problem here,
which says that it's removed 171
rows containing missing values.
So how do you show these
values that are removed?
How do you show missing values
if they're missing? You can use.
geom_miss_point.
This is a regular
plot job and this
will impute the
values of the data
to be lower than the
range of the data.
So the sort of off to the side
here and in a different color.
So let's break
this down and look
at each axis, one at a time.
The values in red on the x-axis
are air temperature values
which are missing for humidity.
We see that the
distribution of these values
here matches the first
cluster on the left.
And on the y-axis are
the humidity values
that have missing air
temperature values.
Interesting again here is that
this cluster of values
seems to match the second
cluster on the right
of the present values here.
So what we learn from
this is that missing this
is a line of these two
classes of air temperature
and humidity.
And let's explore this further
by exploring this relationship
with another variable.
Year. We can just
use facet_wrap year.
Yeah just like a regular plot.
We then get two subplots
here and what we notice
is something very
interesting that we
get these different values
for all these distributions
of missingness are shown for
each of these different years.
And we've learned something
really interesting.
There's a different missing
value pattern for each year.
Now I'm going to briefly
explore some more missing data
visualizations.
So you can use gg_miss_var to
explore the missingness
in each variable
and you can even
show this instead of the
number to the percent,
and you can even explore
this with a facet. Hey, look,
we found it again.
The pattern of missing values
for each year in our data set.
You can use gg_miss_upset
to explore combinations
of missingness in simple data
sets or more complex ones.
You can even use gg_miss_fct
to explore
of missing of all variables
grouped by another factor.
Here we see of missing
data over all variables
in this data set for
these different levels
of marital status.
Want some help from
the R Consortium
I'm really happy to say we'll
be adding some more tools
for visualizing missing data.
I'll briefly talk
about two new additions
that I think would
be really cool.
geom_miss_histogram will show
the amount of missing values
alongside a univariate
distribution
by below the range of the data.
This gives us a general
sense of the amount
of missing values
in the air temperature
data here in this example.
geom_imputed_point will
take in a data set
and identify any imputed values.
And will also show the
values that are missing.
And in some very exciting news
I would love to introduce
a book that I'm working
with, Allison Horst,
called the missing book.
It contains exercises on missing
data in general workflows
and on exploring missing
values and imputations.
And the aim is to
have a general book
to guide you through exploring
your data with some case
studies of real missing data.
So I'll wrap up now by saying
that the future of missing data
is its presence, its
presence in software,
in your data analysis
and tutorials,
and how we think
about data generally.
Funnily enough, missing data
is almost always present.
So let's make sure
we don't forget it.